這場對談辦在美國柯蓋德大學的體育館
時間是今年 9 月的家長週末
台上坐的是歐巴馬
光是 AI 這一題
他就講了將近 20 分鐘
他說最近喊著要放慢的那幾家 AI 公司
是真的在擔心自己的產品
可是管 AI 終究要靠政府
題目是主持的校長出的
AI 這個工具每天都在變
卻握在少數幾家私人公司手上
民主社會要怎麼管
好，大家坐穩了。我可能…我可能得…
我當過參議員，這聽起來可能會像冗長辯論，
不過這一題我要花點時間，我想講得深一點
我不認為這項技術被過度炒作
它的商業效益也許被炒作了
AI 公司的估值也許被炒作了
但技術本身沒有
這件事我追了很久
2015、2016 年，我總統任期的最後兩年，我就在盯這件事，
找了這個領域最頂尖的一批人組成委員會，
談的不只是技術，還有它牽涉到的政治、社會、經濟、倫理問題
最後出了一份很棒的報告
看來它跟我那份防疫計畫，進了同一個垃圾桶
接我位子的那個政府沒有接手
所以我們早就看得到它要來，但它影響這麼深，有一部分是因為它會加速
現在發生的事情是，我們走到了所謂「遞迴學習」這一步，
這件事我們當年就料到了，只是現在親眼看到，
機器開始有辦法自己教自己
它們不用等人類，自己就能開始把事情弄懂
打個比方，人類是老師，AI 模型是學生，
大概一年前，這些模型學到的東西有 90% 是人類老師教的，
也許有 5% 到 10%，它們能自己補上空缺、自己想通…
不到一年，可能連六個月都不到，現在已經是一半一半
趨勢不變的話，預期會倒過來變成 90 比 10
這代表什麼？如果 AI 的學習曲線原本長這樣，
現在我們正碰上曲棍球棒往上翹的那個轉折，
模型會越來越聰明、越來越強，速度快得多，是指數型的速度
這樣會有什麼風險？
有一種是科幻片那種大風險，哇，這些模型變得比我們聰明，
然後它們認定，人類是不錯，但沒有也沒關係
它們開始自己定目標，然後殺手機器人把我們殺光，或者我們向它們下跪
這種風險我不想誇大，
但我要說，這種事發生的機率不是零
不過這其實不是我最擔心的風險，雖然它最受關注
它之所以算風險，不見得是因為電腦模型有意識，
也不代表它們一定對人類懷有惡意
問題只在於，一旦它們開始自己排議程，
它們想做的事，跟我們要它們做的事，就可能對不上
這個落差可能很危險
好，這是第一個問題
更嚴重的問題是，這些模型越來越強，強到落進壞人手裡，就能拿來做壞事
它們可以用某些方式被當成武器，可以惹出很多麻煩
這才是大得多的危險
第一種危險，也就是所謂的奇點、超級智慧接管一切，
如果說那種事發生的機率還算小，
那脫序的 AI 釀成大亂的可能性就很高
他舉了股市當例子
有人叫 AI 想辦法把投資報酬拉到最高
手段違不違法都不用管
結果整個股市可能被拖垮
接著他又點了兩件事
律師事務所花大錢買 AI
圖的是以後不必靠那麼多新進律師
還有 AI 玩伴，他問台下
想不想要一隻泰迪熊變成自己小孩最好的朋友
還被訓練得跟社群媒體一樣讓人上癮
它走得太快，快到過去這幾個星期發生了一件事，
幾家所謂「前沿公司」的領導人，
也就是在開發最尖端模型的那些人，
自己都怕到開口說，我們得放慢
其中兩家，Anthropic 跟 OpenAI，馬上就要大規模 IPO，
所有員工都會賺進幾百萬、幾十億美元
處在這種位置的公司，居然說「我們的東西有點危險」，這是史無前例的，
「也許我們該停下來，或者放慢」。不是停，是放慢
我講這個，是因為有些人會想，而且會這樣想也情有可原，
這些科技公司喊要放慢，可能只是想把競爭對手擋在外面
大家不信任這些科技巨頭，不信任它們累積的權力，這我懂
但我要說，這一次，他們是真的在擔心自己的產品
好，現在大家都專心在聽了，
好消息是，AI 還是一個工具，是一台機器
它被做成讓你以為它不是，但它就是
這項技術非常精密、非常了不起，但應該把它當工具看，
這就代表，要怎麼用它，我們有得選
你說得對，用得好的話，把它用在開發治療癌症的藥，
它能大幅加快我們讓癌症從世界上消失的速度
如果我們訓練它，叫它去找出零碳排的能源，
它可能想得出安全的核融合方法，
給我們多得多的能源，又不會讓地球暖化
都是真的有用的東西
可是一旦搞錯，結果可能是一團混亂，甚至是一場災難
所以我這個星期的看法是，幾家領先的公司說要放慢，這是好事，
我們應該鼓勵
左派有些人說，不該讓這些公司自己做這個決定
我同意，這不能是長久之計
這件事得由政府來管
我聽到川普在這方面的一位主要顧問主張，市場自己會處理
這些公司會自己解決安全問題，因為它們有十足的誘因
萬一真的有危險，大家去告它們就好，它們會怕賠錢
可是我們對航空公司、藥廠、食品公司都不是這樣
放任市場愛怎麼做就怎麼做，這種經驗我們有 150 年了，
而且都是在深深影響健康跟安全的事情上
所以，有效的政府監管架構沒有東西可以取代
而我們的難題是，大家都知道，現任總統說過那是給輸家的東西
所以我們至少有兩年的空窗，這段時間事情跑得飛快，
而現在這個政府沒有能力、也沒有意願，我認為兩個都是，
去訂出一套認真的監管架構
所以我才認為，我們應該鼓勵業界自己做某種程度的節制，
不是因為它能取代監管，是因為眼前我們大概只做得到這樣，
直到國會跟白宮開始認真看待這件事
我知道有些州會想自己開始立法管，
可是這種事很難一州一州做，就跟槍枝管制一樣
我的家鄉伊利諾州，槍枝管制的法律很嚴，
可是周圍幾個州沒有，所以那些法律起不了作用
而 AI 更危險，動得也更快
AI 自己想做的事
跟人要它做的事對不上
AI 圈把這個叫做對齊問題
就是他前面排第一個的那種風險
不過還有另一種對齊問題，
就是這項技術怎麼用對社會最好，
跟這些公司非賺錢不可的壓力，兩邊對不上
這些公司吸到的資金…花的錢比登月…比阿波羅計畫還多
在基礎建設跟科技上，這是人類史上數一數二的投資，說不定就是最大的
而且錢砸得非常快，投資人要看到報酬
這代表這些公司有壓力，就算他們自己在擔心，
也得拿出對得起這筆投資的模型
現在 AI 最紅的東西叫 agent，代理式 AI
你們有看過《鋼鐵人》的都知道，
鋼鐵人穿著那套裝甲，然後他…我不記得那傢伙叫什麼，Jeeves 之類的，
他只要開口講話，那傢伙帶著英國腔之類的，就回一句「是的，先生」
光靠口頭命令，就把所有問題解決掉
或者你看過《雲端情人》，史嘉蕾喬韓森那個，很酷的代理式 AI
我們就是往這個方向走，
因為大家的想法是，代理式 AI 能讓這些模型到真實世界裡辦事，
當你的助理，取代事務所的新進律師，或是會計師
問題是，這如果是你的商業模式，你就會想把它推出去
有時候你得放它到外面的世界亂跑，才測得出它到底行不行
很多危險就是從這裡來的，因為它不是關在密封的箱子裡
它在網路上，它在看你的銀行帳戶，諸如此類
我舉這個例子是要說，如果我們要 AI 做的只是治好癌症、找到更好的能源，
那根本不需要代理式 AI，也不需要放它在網路上自由亂逛
之所以要這樣做，是因為你得推出一個有人願意掏錢買的產品
社會需要的，跟這些公司面對的商業壓力，就是這樣對不上
不見得是他們想做壞事，是因為他們得撐住那些估值
所以這又多了一個理由，我們真的需要一個有能力的政府，
還有兩黨針對這件事認真談
而且動作要快。我要鼓勵選民盯著這件事
哪個人對這件事拿不出認真的計畫，就是沒有跟上這個時刻
那你大概該去找別人
好了，不好意思講這麼久，但我想…
好。我們要處理的事不只這一件，但這一件很大
歐巴馬說 AI 是工具
怎麼用是人在選
所以他最後把題目丟回給選民
候選人對 AI 拿不出認真的計畫
就換一個人
原影片 67 分鐘
AI 以外
歐巴馬還講了如果讓他開一門民主課會怎麼教
他說美國革命一開始
是一群有錢人不想繳稅
最後他談到希望
他說希望從來就不是盲目樂觀
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。